VOICEOVER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART:
This is the third
in the last of the three
models of city form
that I've been putting forward.
To repeat these models, which is
deduced in classes between 1956
and 1980 by Kevin Lynch and
published in A Theory of Good
City Form, I've adapted them
and added an enormous amount
of them subsequently.
But the basis of the
idea was to put forward
some generalizations
about the form of cities,
and try to see to what extent
they had validity in relation
to current urbanism.
If the cosmic model
paid attention
to the regularity of
nature through the study
of the ecclesiastical
systems, if the machine
model preoccupied it with the
speed with which you could
build new places,
and started off
at the beginnings of modern
commercialism and colonization,
the appreciation of nature
as a model for cities
is even vaguer than the others.
Nature has always been
difficult to define.
Although it's palpable and
existentially accurate,
its breadth is so large, and
it needs a lot of acquisition
in order to transform it
into a viable theory of form
of this form of the city.
Not that it hasn't been used.
In the class today, we'll look
at the examples of urban form
which have set forth principles
of natural accommodation.
I start with a piece from
a German town planner.
First war-- 1948 this man
who had been a Nazi, a regime
architect of the
city of Stettin,
says the following
in his 1948 book
Organische Stadtbaukunst,
Organische Baukunst,
Organische Kultur,
which in English means
organic city planning, organic
architecture, organic culture.
AUDIENCE: What's the
name of the city?
JULIAN BEINART:
Forget about the city.
It's unimportant.
Stettin, it's a northern
city in Germany.
The importance is
his proposition.
The metaphors in his book
are familiar-- the branching
of a tree, the structure
of a leaf, the human lung.
He condemns all
inorganic city forms,
be they simple grids, the
machine model, or products
to the Grand Manner,
the cosmic model.
He says they are static,
which is nonsense.
He faults advocates
of linear cities
for presenting this model as
a complete urban solution.
In itself, the linear
city is incomplete.
City expansion is organic when
it occurs along radial lines
without losing power.
A radial-- an organic town
is not clearly described,
but city expansion
is organic when
it occurs along radial
lines without losing
its interpretal power.
And analogical to
the human body,
it would be like the heart
being able to sustain
an extension of arms and
the legs in the human body
beyond measure.
Of course, it's nonsense.
It actually it doesn't
work that way, certainly
not in the organicism
of the human body.
The heart is in the place where
it is for reasons of geometry,
as well as reasons
of performance.
I conclude, "The city
will stop growing when it
has filled its natural space."
Here, again the term
"natural" is used loosely.
What is the natural
space of a city--
one which is 20
million people in size,
or one which is the size of
Springfield, Massachusetts?
It's nonsense.
He ends up by saying,
"The freedom of appearance
is a precondition of
all natural beauty."
We will then discussing
the sea attributes given
to nature, which are beautiful.
In this crazy phenomenon of
biomorphism in architecture,
in one of the textbooks
published by Yale University
Press--
God forbid that they should
publish books like that,
you are instructed to avoid the
rectangle because it doesn't
perform for human beings as
much as the curved surface does.
It's nonsense.
They are metaphors to be
gained from organic material
and organic processes, which
are close to rectangular form
as it is to bent form.
What is by and large argued
is that man has the capacity,
or should have the
right to borrow
processes and forms which have
worked in previous conditions.
This is an element of history
and an element of science
which we abide by.
How selective you
are and how much
learning it requires to choose
a particular biomorphic example
is open to question.
It is not categorical at all.
The piece I've handed
out to you today--
I haven't got a copy myself,
Here's some examples of
cases which I'm going
to go into in some detail.
At the top of the
first page, it tries
to set out some of
the characteristics
of an organic system.
And then it tries to
argue for the depiction
of these protocols in
the form of settlement.
The diagram below
from the regional plan
of New York 1923, which
says, "The possible state
of the future in which each
part serves its logical function
in support of wholesome
activity and good living."
And a version of Patrick
Geddes' linear valley section,
which I'll go into
later, is below that.
What is the appropriate
space that something
has in a natural system?
Patrick Geddes, the great
Scottish biologist and town
planner, argues for in
this valley section,
which is on the next part.
For him, there is
a natural logic
in the location of quarrying
at a distance from the water.
That a fishing village
would be next to the water,
and that cattle farming
would be somewhere
between market gardening
and arable farming.
In the same way, he tries to
build a section through a town.
Iron and steel far from
the, center from the port.
What locates the furrier
between a woodland goods
store and, I think, a
timber and paper merchant?
It's not explainable.
It's only explainable
according to a geography
of purpose, which is assumed
by this man at the time.
As you'll see, when we talk
more about theories which
derive from the social
sciences, from economics,
they are economic
theories, von Thunen
and others which locate
things in a certain degree
of relationship
with other things.
To argue that this is a
natural state, I debunk.
It's not the natural state
of a shopping center in 2013
in the United States.
I will share in the case study
the Tennessee Valley Authority,
which I'll do later
in this class,
that the conception of nature,
which Roosevelt and Benton
MacKaye and Lewis Mumford
and others, regionalists
and transcendentalists had
in mind in 1933 for seven
American states, has
been modified constantly
since then to today
when there are protests
every few months against
the use of nuclear power,
against the Manhattan
Project, all of which
locate within the TVA idea.
The next page is from a book by
an Englishman, D'Arcy Thompson,
called Growth and
Form, which argues
that the organic
species, as these fish,
do not achieve a new form every
time they change marginally.
He shows that within these
parameters of geometry,
these transformations
take place.
However, in the natural
system, there you
reach the threshold beyond
which if you change,
you start a new entity.
You don't keep on
growing and growing.
Ants don't get to be
as large as elephants.
Cities do apparently
grow to large sizes
without distinctively or
disassociating themselves
from smaller, newer items.
This is the velocity
of new towns.
New town construction
follows the organic model
more than generalized
metropolitan expansion.
The next pages deal with
stages of the Tennessee Valley
Authority, which I'll go
through with you in due course.
They say a few things
about the organic idea,
and then followed
by four major case
studies of its application.
An organism is an
autonomous individual.
Secondly, it has a
definite boundary.
Thirdly, it has a
definite size and shape.
The enlargement of an organic
item beyond its normal size
and appropriateness of
size increase is comedic.
If you enlarge a mouse to
the size of something that
parades down the street
at the Macy's Day Parade,
it is humorous.
It is not a mouse any longer.
It's the human brain,
which has activated
an unnatural premise--
that of rampant enlargement
of an item beyond.
Reduction in natural size
and enormous enlargement
to all the products of the
human brain, not of nature.
If the human brain is part of
nature, of course everything
is natural.
It's interesting to argue as
to whether the human being,
as a superorganism like ants,
does things in similar ways.
How do ants find a new site
for their queen mother ant.
Do you know the phenomenon
of the pheromone?
What is a pheromone?
It's what an ant
secretes when he wishes
to make a mark on the ground.
The way a site is chosen
is through a decision
made by the community to choose
a particular cavity which
has the most pheromones
secreted on it.
Each person has the
right to choose a site,
but the site which has the
most pheromone secreted on it
becomes the maternal site for
the leader of the community.
The grammaticus in
the Roman argument
uses a measuring stick,
a geometrical measuring
[INAUDIBLE] for
casting a shadow.
The astrobiologist
in the cosmic model
uses a system of rules derived
presumably from nature.
I think Feng Shui
is a derivation
of natural observation of
sun and stars and so on.
So in that sense, ants, who are
probably the most sophisticated
of the superorganisms
use techniques
for locating a new
city in similar ways
than the human beings does.
We could secrete
pheromones as voters
and decide on the best
site for a new capital
for the United States,
unlikely though that would be.
This very tension is
[INAUDIBLE] in the notion
of the organic unit,
which is turned over
into the organic
settlement idea.
It's best explained
by an example
from Patrick Geddes in India.
Patrick Geddes is asked by
the Maharajah of Bahadur
to do something
about the malaria
in the town of Balrampur.
Balrampur has water
tanks which are polluted.
And the primary impulse
by the maharajah
is to follow the British example
and get rid of the tanks--
to use what is
called urban surgery.
Geddes says no.
There's something good
about these tanks.
So he says, let us rather
employ old men to clean them
every day setting up a
daily ritual of cleaning,
of cleansing, which
will be picked up
by the kids in the town.
They will deviate
from the ritual.
They will increase the
size of the activity,
and you will have
no more malaria.
So the notion is to use the
organic model to retain.
Geddes does this in his
plan for the reconstruction
of Balrampur.
He says narrow the streets.
Use the space
alongside the buildings
to create greenery and trees.
This will help the
health of the settlement.
So he looks at the chowk, the
traditional enclosed linear
market inside blocks.
And he says, instead
of taking these away,
let's built on them.
Quite the opposite
of what Corbusier
does in Chandigarh
in 1949, where
he uses a sector
form which is derived
either from his work in Bogota
or from the work of Clarence
Stein and Henry Wright
in the American version
of the organic settlement.
I've said before that
the organic [INAUDIBLE]
form reaches limits or
thresholds at which time
the change in form is radical.
The organic idea has
differentiated parts.
These parts are
in close contact,
whether they work together in
from each other in subtle ways.
If I were to improve
the human body,
I would put the heart
lower down in the body.
As we have grown in size,
particularly American men,
the distance from the heart
to the toes becomes enlarged.
And one of the phenomenal
problems with diabetes
is that the vein system from
the heart down to the legs
is at such a large distance
that you get problems
with your feet.
And in severe cases, you have
to have your feet amputated.
So nature doesn't always work.
Obviously, we die,
which an organic model
is something which is
difficult to take account of.
The towns then die.
Yes, in pre-modern
times they did die.
We spoke to our friends who
are not here today, on Tuesday,
about [INAUDIBLE] and
the towns that did die.
It's not clear to
me that urban death
is as finite a phenomenon as
human death or organic death.
We all know we're going to die.
Detroit doesn't know whether
it's going to die or not.
It's lingering in
perpetual disease.
A perpetual disease
may be a prolongation
of the inertia of the settlement
ever since its first form.
I come back again to
Marx's quotation, which
I said in the first
class, where he
said one of the things about the
creation of human settlements
is, for the first time, the
distinction between what
is outside and what is inside.
For a long time, what
is outside with nature
and it was dangerous.
Exeunt [? leones-- ?]
there are lion out there.
Exeunt-- some Latin
phrases, which
describe this
phenomenon regarding
nature as both
beneficial and dangerous.
To survive requires an
understanding of nature
as both beauty and the beast--
when the sun shines after the
floods in Egypt of the Nile.
Idiosyncracity becomes a major
form of culture of phenomenon.
You get a town like
Heliopolis On the other hand,
if the flood destroys
half of your settlement,
because you can't predict
the flood's behavior,
you're dealing with
an untamed beast.
In some strange way, we
have come full circle
around our
appreciation of nature.
We are with climate
change, both facing
on the products of
the wonders of nature,
but for the first
time, as a universe,
perhaps facing the
beast-like qualities
of hurricanes and floods.
So human beings have
always posited, in my view,
between a romantic appreciation
of nature independent
of things.
The closing of the agricultural
communal lands in England
prior to the
Industrial Revolution,
in order to make land for
parks or for the wealthy,
took away the living
substance from poor people,
but created the great provenance
of British romantic parks.
Who decides on nature being
good or bad in that respect?
Nature's value-free.
That's what makes it
so difficult for one
to easily assign value
to natural circumstance.
Let's look very quickly
at two more phenomena.
The two are-- the first
one is fear of homeostasis.
One of the major characteristics
of a human or any animal
organism is its capacity
to repair itself.
When it's too hot, as in
this room this morning,
you start sweating to cool
down your temperature.
You don't need to turn
on a machine-like switch.
It happens.
It's built into the
organism's performance.
Homeostasis is an
important phenomenon.
I've used it at times to
explain urban behavior,
such as the notion that perhaps
the return in the United
States to the
center of the city,
after years of
suburban expansion,
is a homeostatic phenomenon.
There is something in
the organic model which
says if you stretch
resources too far,
you will return to an
original state of balance.
The other one is optimum size.
The organic model of
an elephant is easily
understood by virtue of its
major size as a male elephant.
What is the optimum
size of a dinner party?
What is the optimum size
of most social activity?
You'll recall my using
Dunbar's theory of 150 people
as the appropriate community
for the rapid increase of brain
size.
What about the history
of optimal size?
Aristotle, 30,000.
Leonardo, 50,000.
Ebenezer Howard, 1905
and 1920 Letchworth
and Welwyn Garden City, 30,000.
The first of the
British new towns,
30,000, second [? mark II ?]
generation 50,000,
next 100,000.
Milton Keynes,
250,000 is an optimum.
What do you read
that graph as saying?
What determines the
optimal size of a city?
Come on, you must have--
you've thought about these
things in some way or other
before.
Have a guess.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] geographic
boundaries [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN BEINART: Los Angeles
has geographic boundaries?
It started off as a [INAUDIBLE]
small community in 1781.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: How we can communicate
or transport each other?
If there's technology, we
can do it for further away,
and the boundary of
the city [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
You could do that here, and
it still remains 30,000.
I don't know how to answer
this question absolutely.
I can make a couple of guesses.
The one has to do
with urban health.
If you have high
rates of mortality
and low rates of
birthrate accomplishment,
you probably end up with
something like 30,000 people
as being the largest number
you can secure in general.
I mean, it took from Rome
at the birth of Christ
to London in 1850 for a city
to be a million people in size.
There are guesses in fact
that Angkor Wat reached
a couple of hundred thousand.
There were cities in
India which perhaps did.
But the basic
proposition might have
to do with reproduction
of population.
There's also a
comparative index.
The world's population is
probably increasing and doing
this is with the Industrial
Revolution being here.
So there's a notion that we
constitute an approximate size,
at least to optimum size,
based on the social context
of demography and of
other cultural phenomena.
Yes, absolutely, you
have to be able to move
one part to another.
What is it in our contemporary
ethos and scientific model
of life that allows us to build
cities of 20 million people?
AUDIENCE: Penicillin and drugs?
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, I mean,
since the Industrial Revolution
the world changed
phenomenologically
in almost every respect.
That's why I will start
teaching the second section
of this class largely beginning
with the Industrial Revolution.
The rest is a waste of time.
Not a waste of time.
I'm exaggerating of course.
But in one class, one
can't do everything.
My preference is to start
with the major changes which
took place with urbanization
and industrialization.
So let's leave optimum
size theory for a moment.
It's a strange phenomenon.
We still have a
natural inclination
to order our world according
to certain basic rules.
In the British New Towns of
Ebenezer Howard, Letchworth
and Welwyn Garden City,
Raymond Unwin, the architect
and collaborator said
12 units per acre
is an ideal distribution
of population.
What measures 12 units
at 12 houses per acre,
as an optimum for whom, under
what conditions, and so on.
So just some
characteristic form tools
which emanate from this
model of organic item.
Each community should be a
separate social and spatial
unit as autonomous as possible.
Number 2, the community
should be balanced.
The idea of a healthy
community is heterogeneous.
Again, the modeling it after
the human being, the heart
and the pancreas are
not the same thing.
They have different shapes.
They have different entities.
They work.
You can't have a human--
you can't have an organic
element which is singular.
It has to be multiverse.
And the nuclear family in
many of these settlements
is taken as a model with these
differentiated supporting
roles.
In Sunnyside Gardens,
the development,
which the American Garden
City people did in the Bronx,
Mumford claims that there
were 116 mechanics, 79 office
workers, 55 small tradesmen,
five chauffeurs, and 49
salesmen, plus architects,
writers, intellectuals as well.
This, he was happy to--
he lived there.
He was happy to testify
this as a good town
based on its balance.
Seldom does the organic system
produce indefinite similarity.
So the argument that
it is a model in nature
for support of systems in
harmony with each other
is interesting.
Why the nuclear
family should still
be the model for
urbanization, given
that we have large numbers of
people who are not married,
people who choose not
to marry, for example.
Plus if we wish to extend the
model to a universal model,
what success have we had
in nurturing each other
as a universe?
We cannot, in facing the
fundamental challenge
of climate change,
come to agreement about
[? sustenization. ?]
One has to remember that
it was as recent in 1920
that Woodrow Wilson,
the American president,
went to Paris, and was
received by the largest
crowd in the history
of Paris, which
is a large crowd, because he
proposed that the world take
account of its
organization and prevent
wars, such as the
dastardly 1914 to 1918
war, which the world
had just experienced.
So the idea that there
is something organically
universal about co-operative
systems is not true.
Maybe at the scale of a single
family, if it works out,
if you love each other--
which more and more, seeing that
50% of Americans are divorced,
no longer seems to be the model
as described by organicism.
The neighborhood
unit, Clarence Perry
divined an organic sub-model
called the neighborhood
unit for the regional
plan of New York in 1923,
I think it was.
A neighborhood unit, again,
is organic in its nature.
It argues that a community
should be the size of a quarter
mile walk of a child to school.
Again, the organic
model comes in.
What is the species which has
the least protection naturally?
A child.
So you'll use that as
the model for building
a circular community
around the primary school.
The fact that people
take their kids
to school by
automobile, the fact
that people choose schools
in a democracy based
upon the quality of
school, based on the fact
that the linear model doesn't
allow one to use this model
is distinctive, and so on and
so on, renders this model.
But Radburn, New
Jersey, was based
on the quarter mile walking
distance to schools,
as well as Greenbelt Maryland,
and the American greenbelt
towns.
160 acres around a school.
The next growth optimum size
is the greenbelt. If you
have an optimum size, you can
protect it from the forces that
work against optimization--
nasty forces like the market,
developers, politicians.
When we were working
on Chandigarh
as recently as
1990-something, we
noticed that land was being sold
north of the Capitol Complex,
in the path of this wonderful
diagram that Corbusier
[INAUDIBLE] made of
this town stretching
in an untrammeled fashion
towards the Himalayas.
What we discovered
were real estate signs
for politicians selling land
illegally in this sacred area.
We needed a studio with
the Cambridge University
in England.
We found that the
greenbelt around Cambridge
had, of course,
increased land values,
and Cambridge significantly
had been pocketed
with political development.
The notion which
Ebenezer Howard so
favored in the city of
Adelaide, for building parks
around the center
of the city, has not
proven to be another solution.
First of all, how do
you keep the land green?
You need a maintenance system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: This is a
small example from a mining
town in South Africa.
Gold is discovered--
gold and uranium.
Here's a center built. An open
space is left around the center
so it might grow.
And housing starts here.
This is a hot climate.
No money in the
design of the town
has been invested in
maintaining an open space.
It's a dusty, horrible bubble.
It prevents the centers from
growing, and it's a silly idea.
To be a junior teacher
at Cambridge University,
if you are married, you have
to live beyond the greenbelt.
The British have not
built enough roads
to take care of your
commutation every day.
If you've got two cars,
which you probably
haven't at that
stage in your career,
the wife has to carry--
you can't afford
to live in Cambridge, because
the university has preoccupied
most of the land,
and raised the rent
levels of the rest in the
center to such a degree
that you can't
afford to live there.
So the greenbelt
has turned out to be
a weak weapon against expansion
I'm generalizing.
There are cases where
protective legislation has
changed the pattern of growth.
But the greenbelt as
a generalized idea
is not sufficient in itself.
There's also two other items
with these settlements.
There's a fascination with the
organic quality of production.
Why we believe
that the food which
we buy on stalls next to
the road outside of town
are better and healthier than
food, water in the supermarket
is beyond me.
Perhaps the cost is less
and they seem fresher.
Maybe they are.
Sometimes, they are directly
tilled from the gardens
of the farm next door.
But there is something
assumed to be
natural in the conjunction of
a producer and a purchaser.
This is an archaic
form of goodness.
That if you buy from a
farmer without a middleman--
that the middleman is
an alien phenomenon
in the natural system, the
heart sends blood directly
to the toes.
He doesn't need support systems.
Maybe I don't know human
biology well enough.
Maybe there's this halfway
heart in your knees
which take care of
the support system.
Sometimes these things happen
through complex instruments
of market and culture.
There are now 124
farmers markets
in the County of Los Angeles--
124, spontaneously developed
without any government
intervention, without
any government subsidy.
Just simple rules about
where you may create
a weekly farmer's market.
The attraction of buying
at a farmers market,
as opposed to buying at a
supermarket, are complex.
I have a thesis student
at the moment working--
doing a thesis in Seoul, where
the advent of the shopping mall
has caused havoc with the
informal market system.
And this is true
also in the case
in Hong Kong, which somebody
is trying to replicate
a traditional market system.
These are pointers to elements
of goodness and difficulty
in the blatant acceptance
of organic systems.
One last one is the
question of social equity.
There's a long
tradition of believing
that the value of land
or activity in the city
is not the function
of individuals.
It is the function
of the community's
activities and investment.
Therefore, a private
lot should not
be the beneficiary
of communal growth.
This philosophy was made
explicit in this country
by a man called Henry George,
a middle 19th century economist
philosopher who wrote a book
called Progress and Poverty.
The Lincoln Land Institute
here in Cambridge
is a follower of the
Henry Georgian view.
It raises difficulties.
In English town planning up
till reasonably recent times,
there was always a conflict
between the payment
of betterment or the
penalizing of people.
For instance, if I
have a gas station
on a normal arterial
road and a decision
is made to build a
national highway,
and I'm given the
right to put my gas
station on the
national highway, I
contributed nothing to the world
to pay me for this goodness.
But can I be penalized?
Can I be given a negative
option on its location?
It's much like if
you decide to wash
my car without my permission.
Am I entitled to pay you or not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
No.
JULIAN BEINART: No.
You're right, no.
On the other hand,
if I own a gas
station on an arterial road,
and the government decides
to close the road, I mean, am
I entitled to compensation?
These are all elements
in the land change system
that we now have rules about.
But according to Henry
George, and before him even
our great Abraham Lincoln--
I won't be able to find his
quotation, has this notion
that land is only
a temporary gift.
That the communal work done
by the government-- of course,
Lincoln is a big
government sponsor.
It is a strange idea,
seeing he was a Republican.
But the organic model
in Sunnyside Gardens,
for instance, the
communal value increase
of the property over
a certain period
is returned to the seller of
a particular unit of land.
Let's carry on and see if we
can get through this stuff
more quickly.
There's also an organic
model, as I mentioned before.
Interest in
non-orthogonal forms--
radial patterns,
bounded units, focus
centers,
anti-geometrical layouts,
irregularly curving organic
shapes, natural materials,
and so on.
Three years after he
designed Central Park,
Olmsted laid out a
piece of flat prairie
land a couple of
miles outside Chicago.
He suggests, and
I quote from him,
"Curved streets
suggest and imply
leisure, contemplativeness,
and happy tranquility.
In contrast is
straight streets, which
imply eagerness to press forward
without looking to the right
or left.
Riverside was called
a suburban village."
I will show you in the
slides the plan of Riverside.
Its separate parts are all
designated by curved roads.
In 1873, the Northern
Pacific Railroad
asked Olmsted to do a layout
for a new town of Tacoma,
Washington, a plan
that exploited
the topography of the site.
According to some
reporter, "Olmsted's plan
was the most fantastic plan
of a town that was ever seen.
There wasn't a straight line,
a right angle, or a corner lot.
The blocks were shaped
like melons, pears,
and sweet potatoes.
One block shaped like a banana
with 3,000 feet in length
and had 250 plot.
It was a pretty plan for a
park, but condemned itself
for a town."
It was never built.
Let's look at some of
these individual cases.
Patrick Geddes was a
young Scottish biologist
who went to work for one
of the great 19th century
biologists, Thomas Huxley,
and according to legend,
deciphered the mechanism by
which a frog's eye operates.
He didn't get the benefit
of it, so Huxley did.
But Geddes went on to be
interested in urbanism.
He is regarded as one
of the great minds
in urbanistic history--
modern urbanistic history.
Charles Darwin said,
"I have read several
of your biological papers
with very great interest
and I've formed, if you'll
permit me to say so,
a high opinion in
your abilities."
Einstein, Rabindranath
Tagore, Mahatma Gandhi all
speak highly of,
Lewis Mumford says
of Geddes, one of the truly
seminal minds, and so on.
I'm just going to go through a
couple of ideas of Geddes' that
emerge from our understanding
of the best uses of nature.
First of all, he believes
in the civic survey.
He [INAUDIBLE] in India to
do a plan for a new town that
has trouble.
He insists on the town
first doing a civic survey.
A civic survey is
not only a method
of capturing what exists
accurately on the land.
It is a way of revealing the
possibilities of retaining
the pieces that work.
In his plan for Balrampur,
the civic survey
shows what is
existing in the land.
He then decides to extract
from those the elements that
need improvement, the
elements that can be retained,
the elements that
can be built on.
Secondly, he believes in the
synoptic version of nature,
getting multiple
visions to coincide
with similar ends similar
to native elements of life
in nature.
For him in nature, it is
possible for all things
to come together, and for
us to understand that.
He uses a diagram from the
French philosopher Laplace,
which is a right angle crossing
in which the corners are
acts, deeds, dreams, facts.
If you begin this piece of
paper along these vertical and
horizontal lines, each of
them comes into each other.
He then breaks down the
components of each sector.
What is it about
dreams of the imagined?
What is it about the imagination
that has to do with work?
It's a diagram which
a child can play with.
But it's, for me anyway, more
of an indication of his notion
that simultaneity is
a fundamental property
of organicism, and can
be utilized effectively
in practice.
He's asked to do a plan for the
Hebrew University of Jerusalem
after 1917.
And his son-in-law,
who was an architect,
does a plan with him.
Again, everything about the
plan of the universities,
which I show you in these
slides, deals with synopticism.
At the center of the university
plan is a domed space.
Why does he use the dome?
He says the dome is the
only architectural form that
is revered by Christians,
Jews, and Muslims.
So even an architectural
form, which
resonates with different
often conflicting cultures,
he says there's no
reason for these people
to kill themselves over
things like a dome.
The fingers, which
move out from the dome
locate aspects of
the knowledge system
of the university in
sequence, one after the other.
For you to get from
architecture to the center,
you have to go through biology.
Much like the folded the
diagram of a piece of paper
which connects dreams
and work and play
and ideas, this
planned university
is an attempt to resonate
along the same system.
MIT's perhaps closer in
its stupid grid system
to this synopticism
than anything
that Geddes ever envisioned.
He put something called the
[INAUDIBLE] tower in Edinburgh
to take people up into
the top of the tower
to look down at the town.
For him, understanding and
learning about the town
was an important element
in civic education.
You needed to know
about the town
in order to fulfill your role as
a member of a community, which
had something to
do with the change
of the shape of the place.
He proposed things
like civic exhibitions.
He made a civic exhibition
of the ideal town.
It was damaged and destroyed
en route to India on a ship.
He nevertheless maintained
this fundamental idea
of human nature is learning.
It is what Kevin Lynch
stressed as distinguishing
the human being from
other animal species--
brain size and its
capacity to learn.
For Geddes, the human being
was central as a humanist.
But he had observations
about the way in which nature
we could accompany
the human learning
capacity in the generation
of good systems.
Participation of people is
now an accepted political
of creation of modern urbanism.
The attempt by
some of the people
we'll see in a few minutes
to coordinate and make
sense of the inner world
and the outer world
of transcendentalists,
like Benton MacKaye
in the United States--
the notion that you
can both cooperate
nature and the economy,
such as the Tennessee Valley
Authority the new regionalism.
God, can you imagine
in the United States
today getting seven states
in the American South
to agree that the
central government would
make a plan for all of them?
It's nonsense.
This capacity to
see natural regions
as natural phenomena outside
of political boundaries
is Geddesian idea.
The greatest piece
of human intervention
in our time in this country
must be the Tennessee Valley
Authority.
I'll end up these profiles with
a quick look at the Tennessee
Valley Authority.
Ebenezer Howard was
a young Englishman
who drifted to the United
States at the age of 21
because he had
uncle in Nebraska.
He was a dreamer.
He learned rapid
transcription in Chicago.
Came back to England, made a
living as a court reporter,
but had the idea
that new towns could
be the salvation of
industrial chaos.
He was the founder of what
is called the Garden City
movement, and he
built two towns.
Can you imagine a man with
that economic background
being the sponsor of two towns?
Letchworth in 1905,
about 80 miles
from London, and Welwyn
Garden City in 1920,
these were towns which
followed certain naturalistic
principles.
They were meant to take what
is best of the center city,
take what is best
of the countryside,
and amalgam the two in a kind of
urbanistic master mix machine.
It would be identifiable
parts of this community,
and so on and so on.
The Garden City movement
had universal appeal.
Mumford regards it as the
most extensive influence.
He says that the book
Garden Cities of To-Morrow
has done more than
any other single book
to guide the modern
town planning
movement toward its objective.
We can't pay much more
attention to this movement.
In the United States,
we have Clarence Stein
and Henry Wright's book
Towards New Towns for America.
The Regional Planning
Association of America in 1923
was a group of
architects, planners,
exponents of conservation,
sociologists,
and economists who came
together to make greater
sense of American urbanism.
They were influenced
by the British Patrick
Geddes, who was invited to
come and talk to them in 1923.
They mixed a strange
kind of religious element
of transcendentalism,
the movement
started here in
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
on the 8th of September
1836 by people
like George Putnam, Ralph Waldo
Emerson, and Frederic Henry
Hedge.
Nature was the vehicle which
associated the mind and nature,
and not nature was [INAUDIBLE].
Combining the mind and the
body through the element
of nature was one of the--
there was not enough to be
argued in the functional
plan of things.
There had to be some
transcendental-- some larger,
ethos associated.
And this ethos was not
in conventional theism
or religion, but in an invented
religion without religion--
a naturalist religion of a kind.
And so we go through
Sunnyside Gardens in Radburn
in New Jersey.
[INAUDIBLE] another
5 or 10 minutes.
I'd rather spend the time on
talking about the Tennessee
Valley Authority
as a case study.
In 1930, the condition of
the region was as follows.
30% of the region was
afflicted by malaria, others
by hookworm, pellagra,
and black lung disease.
The income was $639
per year per family.
Much of the farmland had
been eroded or depleted.
In Tennessee alone, 14 million
acres needed reclamation.
10% of the forests were
being burnt each year,
and the river long
used for transportation
by Native Americans had
been clogged by floods.
The area covered by the--
over 90% of the people had
no electricity in 1930.
30% had no toilets, and 65%
had to walk over 250 meters
to get water.
There are a number of
responses to this situation.
The first was the
response by a group
who called themselves
the Southern
Agrarians, an intellectual group
who claimed that farmers were
ancient pioneers of hardy
stock, capable of sustaining
themselves and only
wanting to be left alone.
Twain had eulogized the
great rivers of the South
in the new language of nature.
Beaten by the North
in the Civil War,
the South resisted the
invasion of their nature
by metropolitanization by
the [INAUDIBLE] centralized
and the impersonal nature
of modernism, machines,
and the central government,
which the TVA represented.
See, here, we have a reaction
to this kind of condition.
Leave it to us.
Do not intervene.
Do not bring
large-scale intervention
to bear on us people.
We have lived through turmoil
before, and we have managed.
This is an ethos
of conservation.
The second perspective
was that held by Roosevelt
and his colleagues, who
led to the creation in 1933
of an authority which had
large rights to change
this seven-state environment.
Roosevelt was very
influenced in regionalism
by people like Benton MacKaye.
Mumford strongly supported--
who met with Roosevelt before he
signed the TVA proclamation.
The ethos, if there was one in
Roosevelt's team, was, I quote,
"Multi-use use and
seamless environments,
trees and nature are means to
solve almost any human problem,
touching every river and
creek and [INAUDIBLE] touches
and gives life to all
form of human concerns."
If this isn't a naturalistic
view, I don't know what is.
Yeah.
The TVA proceeded after
'33 to develop fertilizers,
told farmers how
to have great crop
yields and replant forests,
controlled forests.
Devastation floods created
an irrigation channel,
which carries more than
50 million tons of goods
on the Tennessee River.
They built 29
hydroelectric dams,
which made the TVA the nation's
largest power company, and so
on.
A third alternative
view of what was
seen as socialist
intervention was
that proclaimed by Henry Ford.
Henry Ford in 1921 offered
Congress $5 million
to buy the Wilson dam
and the power facilities
to develop his alternative
to Roosevelt's TVA.
Ford soon saw nature through
the lens of agriculture,
which he believed had
been mistakenly ignored
in the making of American
Industrial cities.
To create a machine-agriculture
balance that is
a machine-nature balance,
Ford proposed to build a city
in a town called Muscle Shoals--
muscle in-- muscle,
like on the human body,
and shoals, S- H- O- A-
L- S. 120 kilometers long
and 24 kilometers wide, made
of a string of small towns
from which workers
commute to his factories.
Ford was rejected by Congress,
led by Senator Norris, who
claimed this act of revitalizing
the Tennessee Valley
Authority should be
done by the public,
not by the private sector.
A strange thought these days.
Since 1973, there have been
new conceptions of nature
that have little to do with
the romance of tradition
nor with the efficiency
of relational regionalism,
nor the reclamation of
agriculture through industry.
First, in 1973, the
construction of the Tellico Dam
on the Little
Tennessee was halted
when a rare 9
centimeter long fish
was discovered in these waters.
The fish, which
was claimed to be
a unique species and
a potential demise
became a watershed event
in the growing American
environmental movement.
It was taken to the
United States Supreme
Court, who upheld the
environmentalists' protests.
Since the controversy,
the small fish
has been relocated to another in
Tennessee, where it's thriving.
The snail darter
[? conservaty ?] still stands.
The interesting thing
about a 9 centimeter fish--
it's not quite interesting
about it, I must admit.
But what is interesting is that
it's within the large Tennessee
Valley Authority, which we've
seen in relation to differing
views about nature.
Here's a microscopic element
of nature causing an attempt
to stop a dam.
In the 1950s, as the
demand for electricity
was outstripping the capacity
of the hydroelectric facilities,
the TVA began to build
coal-fired electric plants,
which account for about 65%
of its electricity output.
Why I'm telling
you this story is
to indicate for
you, in one project
over 70 years, the
conflicting and differing
ways in which
nature is introduced
as the basis for critique
and for revision.
Nobody cared about small
fish in the dams in 1933.
Cultural and
technological change
produced a new way
of discovering nature
in the water.
The original idea to
generate electricity
through the building
of hydroelectric
turned out by 1950 not to be
producing enough electricity.
So they switched to coal, which
now is the predominant energy
source.
On December the 22nd, 2008,
an earthen dike at one
of the plants at Lincoln broke,
spilling a billion gallons
of wet coal ash across
300 acres of land
and into the tributaries.
The New York Times
in the next day
called it quote, "The largest
environmental disaster
of its kind in the
United States."
In 1943, the US government
built the Oak Ridge Laboratory
in Tennessee as part of
its Manhattan Project
to separate and produce
uranium 13 for use
in developing a nuclear weapon.
We start with a problem.
We have reactions
to probably invoking
the best use of nature.
The idea of nature,
the level at which it
had seen and discriminated
changes over time,
over 80 years, we now have a
completely different view--
not a completely different view.
We have a different
set of tools with which
to understand nature.
So it argues as
much for there not
being a fixed and determinant
view of nature superseding
almost every
possible alternative
view, but a fluctuating
view of nature
as an important phenomenon
in human existence.
This adds strength to
the idea that the city
is a phenomenon of change.
And we will, in our
subsequent classes,
be looking carefully at
theories which attempt
to accommodate these changes.
How Roosevelt in 1933 could have
known about the snail darter,
I don't know.
But I do know he
couldn't have known.
This is the forward to
[? Ilya ?] [INAUDIBLE]
father's book on the city.
It shows plans of London.
There is no evaluation,
other than visually,
it looks like cancer.
That it may be performing
better in terms of social equity
than under Henry
VIII is not an issue.
He is an architect and looks
at patterns of architecture,
and derives the observation
that not only is this a more
complicated and
more complex problem
to be resolved pattern-wise.
He would apply
that solution to it
that is identifiable small
units, either neighborhood
or idiosyncratic
environments or patterns,
in a way which isn't as
fragmented and difficult
as this.
This is a plan for the
metropolis of tomorrow
by Victor Gruen, who simplified
things everywhere he could.
The task is to learn how to
identify patterns in this kind
of environment which are
good and which are bad,
as opposed to creating
a new geometry,
which for elementary reasons
cannot accept a city form,
which is on the
bottom on the left.
Next.
Patrick Geddes, the Scottish
biologist and town planner.
The Laplace diagram-- if
you follow the black lines,
you follow the acts, deeds,
thoughts, facts all together.
Experience and ideation,
work and synergy,
all are part of segments
of thought and feeling,
experience emotion,
ethnopolity, synergy and so on.
The whole idea is
that everything
in the human experience
touches on everything else.
It was a kind of vision
of a synoptic world which
could make sense of
everything, but particularly
in the relationship
between things.
Next.
So one would expect
the Hebrew University
plan, which he did with
his son-in-law, who
was an architect.
The center is a center.
That is a biological constant.
It's fundamental.
If you believe [INAUDIBLE],,
it's built into archaic man.
The dome on the
building is a form
which is the only architectural
form which is accepted by Jews,
Islam, and Christianity.
So bringing all
these things together
suggests a form which
can deal with all three
at the same time.
The ideation
context, the branches
of science and the humanities,
and the various aspects
of knowledge are branched
out in arms from the center
in order to go from
the bottom on the left.
I don't know what it is.
In order to get
to the center you
have to pass through
other bodies of knowledge.
Again, the whole
idea is that what
makes a human
environment most powerful
is the capacity to capture
more than one element
of human experience.
When I talked today about
a number of social science
theories of city
form, this aspect
will be particularly missing.
The valley section--
there is a natural place
for things in a system.
He's wrong.
There is nothing natural
about that at all.
The soil condition will
determine to some extent
the kind of--
but we will see another
version of this in von Thunen's
diagrams in southern
Germany in the beginning
of the 19th century,
which also lays out
a pattern of distribution,
but it's largely
as a function of
transportation costs.
Milk is produced close to
the center of the city.
Further out is cream.
Why?
What is natural about cream
being further from the center?
Cream is produced in
smaller volumes than milk.
Therefore, the transportation
costs are less.
It's assuming all transportation
is towards the center.
Secondly, cream perishes
less rapidly than milk,
so it's resistant to longer
transportation possibilities.
Here, the valley
diagram just assumes
there's a natural
rightness of location.
There is no natural
Next.
OK, he's working in one
of the Indian towns.
This is Balrampur,
and he uses items,
such as conservative surgery.
Rather than bulldozing what
the maharajah called the slum,
he looks to the possibilities
of cosmetic surgery,
investing energy and
money in key items.
But basically,
probably what is there
is considered as good in
itself, rather than the erasing.
The notion here is
that you cannot--
by erasing a system, you retain
very little of its capacity
to introduce new items.
It's one of the problems
of new settlements.
They don't have the built-in
connection between history
and memory and newness.
You can see how Geddes'
mind as a biologist
exerts itself in
a number of items.
Ebenezer Howard,
on the other hand,
sees the distinction between
the central city and the country
as the basis of making a
division between the two.
Next.
He postulates the town country
has low rents, high wages,
plenty to do.
Town is bad, country is great.
But country is dumb,
town is too expensive.
Town-country brings together
all the best things.
No sweating, pure air and
water, cooperation, no smoke.
Why should there
be more cooperation
in a town-country phenomenon
than in an urban setting?
You may argue that in fact,
quite the opposite is probably
true.
That the higher proportion
of people likely to cooperate
learn to cooperate in a dense
environment than in a loosely--
but that's not at
issue for Howard.
Howard's a man who learned
to be a court reporter,
but had the practical
genius of an Englishman
to build new towns.
Next.
Here, you can see it again.
Yesterday, this is Manchester
as described by Engels.
Today, tomorrow, living
and working in the sun
at Welwyn Garden City,
one of the two cities
that Ebenezer Howard proposed.
The early romanticization
of suburbia,
it produces nature in
a domesticated form.
Here's this benign husband
and wife and little daughter
sitting in a man-made garden.
People are friendly.
Next.
The greatest asset--
the Garden City movement
became an international
phenomenon.
It was taken up by
the Regional Planing
Association of New York in
1923 as one of its great goals.
Here, you can see
some of the charm.
There's a lot of invention in
site planning in these towns.
Let's skip and go
on to some of those.
Next.
The idea-- this is
Letchworth, 1905.
But there was also the idea
that you could break up
the facade of a street,
largely straight because
of a mechanical system, by
identifying opportunities
or creating a different
relationship to the street.
Next.
You can see some of the
items of this invented idea.
First of all, the cul-de-sac--
traffic should not run along
its clearly identified path.
It should be stopped.
The cluster, the
road which bends
informs the curve, the
retention of our buildings.
So again, here is a combination
of the old and the new.
And landscaping became
an important part
of the manifestation of space.
Different types of
landscaping in the form
of large trees, small trees.
This, in my view, is
the major contribution
of Garden City knowledge.
Next.
Here is Nuovo Quartiere
of Villini, a Garden City
suburb in Milano.
They occur in Cape Town.
They occur all over the world.
The shopping center,
again, underscaled.
In relation to in
the United States,
the ratio of parking
space to floor space
would be phenomenally
larger than here.
And one of the problems
with these kinds of towns
has been the increase
in car population.
Next.
The Regional
Planning Association
in the United
States-- this is again
a diagram of Victor
Gruen, showing
how unsubtle the
simultaneous relationship
with Patrick Geddes spoke of.
Yes, there are people who
walk and there are people
who travel longer distances.
That they need to be separated
by a mechanical system
is stupid.
It involves an introduction
of a new infrastructure, which
is relatively purposeless.
You can take apart
all the elements.
But the idea of
cleanliness, of a kind of--
the Victor Gruen plan,
the Washington plan,
has a kind of clarity
of fundamentalism,
which is supposedly
attractive, whereas in fact,
the cancer-like
planned of London
has items in it which have a
higher degree of intelligence
than this.
This is a lower level
of intelligence.
The organic model again.
The possible state of the
future in which each part serves
its logical function in
support of wholesome activity
and good living.
Each part has its right place.
Central Park, a model
of the insertion
of a natural phenomenon
by Olmsted and Vaux.
I think it's 1859, I'm not sure.
And Olmsted, the
progenitor of much the idea
of the cosmic model--
sorry, organic model,
planned for Riverside
just outside of Chicago.
The curved surface,
no straight lines,
idiosyncratic, speed at
movement through the complex.
Next.
Sunnyside Gardens.
Well on the left Clarence Perry
neighborhood theory measuring
the safe walking distance
of a child to school
is giving a density of
an appropriate walking
[INAUDIBLE].
And Sunnyside Gardens,
Stein and Wright's
complex, where you
internalize the urban world
into a safe environment and
treat it as a communal asset,
with everybody
contemplating the unity
of the social circumstance
which created.
Over time, each owner
started building
particular private
space enclosures
eating into the public space.
But in recent years,
there's been an attempt
to reformulate the
original open space.
I don't know if that's Lewis
Mumford, but he lived here.
Next.
Chatham Village, a number
of these layouts occurred.
Chatham Village in Pittsburgh.
Next.
The phenomenon is the same--
the predominance of nature, the
separation of places to walk
and places to drive, the
capacity to fix things
in your own property, the
kind of control of the world,
and really good neighborly
relationship between houses,
at least that is accepted
without somehow the community
is energized by the fact
that the whole system is made
pro-humano in some way--
so it is thought.
A good biological system
will animate its users
to believe in it.
You have no way of not
believing in your body.
Next.
That's Radburn, New
Jersey, on the left based
on walking distance of children
and the externalization
of automobiles.
Next.
The greenbelt towns built under
the Roosevelt administration--
again, the walking
distance of children,
and the use of major
curved geometries
to enhance the fact that the
buildings and the streets
are not subject to
simple mechanization.
But the patterns of the
street in themselves
would animate or lead
to an understanding
of the natural
quality of this place.